hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Kreischer custom story out of
it we are being chased by bad guys there
they are in the sky I'm not gonna waste
ammo on them because you hardly ever
need in wait didn't I just come in that
place all right this was loud maybe I
need ah is that a hole in the fence it
is oh yeah it's a hole in the fence
get through there yeah oh yeah I got it
oh it's an eyeball oh it's a heart
anybody want to jump
oh it's shot I don't need a good luck
toggle iron sights oh yeah I forgot that
I could do any place there's the syringe
that looks like one of those breakable
boxes from half-life if I remember
correctly Oh what ah [ __ ] you I'm gonna
get you I'm gonna get you up can't get
me up here Oh what's wrong with your
legs oh that's so sad for you dead
okay no parent can't break that box
--cat damn jump out at me these things
like to jump out of me okay reloaded
we're gonna go
I see you back there I see you hat Oh
pop goes the head cami
give me your knock cuz the Glock this
this gun only has eight bullets I think
it's the most powerful gun but can only
hold eight bullets at a time in the amo
is rarer there's something in here that
I need go through here go around here I
don't see any keys oh there it is lobby
key pool lobby no no there was there
pool does it mean like kulagin table
pool pool table or pool is in Oh over
here this must be it yeah I'm pretty
sure I'm pretty sure this is it for sure
there we go yeah yeah
Oh
[Music]
I don't appreciate the music
Oh
Oh God
Oh girl [ __ ] you yeah yeah Oh
pwned you up
hardcore now what I learned from my
playthrough last time is that it is
possible to get like ah inventories
[ __ ] fall alright get rid of the get
rid of the switchblade cuz like with all
these guns who needs it anyway and I can
punch things with my fists if I need to
melee something conference from P
depression how people live are not open
another awesome is it
Oh hmm nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope
[ __ ] you dance get ready for de shout
gun yeah goon that's what I thought
stumbling guys getting scary ya ain't
even little scary maybe I should save my
powerful handgun
yeah I probably should just cuz the mo
is gonna be rare Glock ammo drops from
actual monsters so I'm not worried about
that I haven't asked save in a while
Thomas Oh dad miss something ham let me
I I got this key but I think wait hang
on let me just double-check the bodies
are gone no I just want to check in on
all the doors back there for this room
cuz oh oh
see ya si si si si si ha
I look afraid of Oscars
norm karlik adopt era and while north a
dog unlike that will do hunting and
knowns are stark horns miss bukhara
Carnac as kept um some Linga gone garb
our master to Thunder pooling peeling I
don't know I don't know okay where's the
pool
at the pool area oh okay where's the
okay it must be back this way I swear
every time those doors shut sounds like
a monsters like Nilda her ha or whatever
the hiss is by the monsters do when they
come after me okay
[ __ ] off
jammed and something on the other side
is moving against the door
okay that's lovely
oh here's a save
oh that's where time moves so slowly
want to playing these games
goo-goo-goo do things the explode walk
da hell you're the big guy the fat
goober
you'll pool kids no running in the pool
ah no way here we go and you you you're
one of the bosses aren't you weren't you
just something that I need little boy
hey buddy have you got something I
desire I think I can kill you
I remember ayah to kill you a special
way before I can't get in the pool
oh I can okay all right
oh I see it I see it oh crap I see it oh
good I hear yeah I see it is it gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme
ah ah ah ah let me up
you're gonna Myrtle eyes my face oh yeah
here today I only got a good one thing
ah I get I hear I want I want out I want
out oh [ __ ] me I'm so bone
I look it out would kill you news use a
flotation device
damn it here ah almost got me come on
let me out yeah yeah I don't even need
that image needed climb out this yeah
that was it I didn't even need the
freaking ladders what kind of idiom em I
which is right there Oh idiot okay I got
the exit door key
really I needed to go through all that
just to get to the exit
okay whatever though
it's fine whatever
I complaining
Hey look it's an exit oh wait this one
came in Oh dog smart dog smart oh that's
the exit okay can I get out here please
with a nothing bad happening uh looks
good this looks real good
oh boy that's not doing anything what is
that oh it's a big guy
oh no worried about big guys big guys
are exactly oh hello are you doing down
there Crawley one okay so big guy hey
are you protecting something that I need
oh you feel ugly and freakishly tall
how's the weather up there big guy Oh No
and he's guarding nothing okay
whose stairs what was that huh it's like
a what top hey you want to come join the
party up a bit pick up whom the hell I
said boom hey buddy
don't mind me I'm still convinced that
guy could probably one shot me was like
a way to get up there and knowing now
worth worrying about
up dude it took you long to help I said
wrong and you won't right Oh big I can't
go downstairs all right nope
that's what I thought okay so
alright hey there's nothing down here
cheonsik um yeah isn't nothing down here
wait ho here we go
no no no no no aah I do need to go in
through there ah I do I do I do I do i
do what do i do ooh okay so I'm just
gonna leave this guy back here cover my
running juice it's still better hey
about it you're so ugly
Oh your face is so weird and flat good
like a flat head is it come okay there
we go okay yeah okie dokie
there we go all right we're good now
don't know I couldn't have just gone
through that door but whatever oh oh I
don't even get it in choice in the
matter
oh the end what what no way that can't
be it
uh-huh
what about the whole two months earlier
crap what
what
uh I can still access my inventory I
just can't select anything
huh
I can't have been hit maybe it was it
maybe that was all there was to it
I mean it is a community campaign but I
doubt that it would be included with
another update if it was just that cuz
that's like that's a supremely
disappointing ending I can't be right
can't be right I can't do anything ah
there we go
man Italy what what was it what was
going on oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
actually I'm gonna have to cut it here
thank you all so much for watching I'm
gonna figure this out in the next
episode so thank you all so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part bye-bye